[Music]
what is up
oh my god
let's go let's go
bro that that was crazy that was wild I
felt like I was in the halls of uh the
Congress on January 6th that was
excitement holy hello everybody Welcome
to the one trillion dollar the SEC the
defense SEC uh Ministry I don't know
what country Secretary of Defense
Department of Defense has given us this
they lost like a trillion dollars in
Iraq so ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic teams
folks we're in the Pentagon black budget
you already know what that's about jsoc
operations happening in popping fields
in Afghanistan only to fund the best and
brightest that's right
anyways well it's leftovers it is what
it is hello Hassan welcome back nice to
see you it's great to be here sun's out
I I know sun's out you you love that
you posted this yeah is this like an
ongoing goo yeah I always post like a
little titty okay like I give a little
titty I give a little titty to the
people out there and then some people
like it [__] ditch some people say like
they get uncontrollably horny in the
middle of the day when they see it you
know what I mean yeah I feel that people
will be like dude I just turn it on
my what my heart flutters and sings this
song yeah yeah you know I realize my
nipples really small bro you know what
else I realized I have white chest hairs
you do not
yeah no I don't know dark as hell bro I
don't have white hair anywhere but my
head yeah and I I don't have like I mean
I have some white like beard Grays
coming in but I have white chest like my
chest hair is just white as hell right
hand let's see let's do a nip like I
don't know what the [__] what does that
mean that my nipple is so small does
that mean I have cancer or something no
what is that red dot next to your nip
though on the other yeah what is that oh
it's like a
it's like I don't know what do you call
those it's just like a I don't know what
it is I've never seen one it's called a
tumor no oh it's like a it's like a mole
yeah it's like a little mold like a
little blood mold okay exactly exactly
did everybody watching leftovers think
you're going to be getting into you know
this this early I got the start baby
free the nipple yeah what I say
but actually I'm pretty proud of how the
perspective worked out in my uh it's
quite quite a striking it's a good
perspective what you got to do is get a
little bit more undercarriage though
what you didn't right you didn't you
didn't showcase like the the shade I got
you underneath the titty right there I'm
proud of it honestly uh it's one of the
most important parts for sure yeah yeah
I've been I've been you know I've been
working out a lot I wanted to I wanted
to Showcase it a little bit I don't want
to get too [__] with it I want to get
a little [__] so that's what I was
perfect amount of [__] for me thank
you on a you know
well you're study with it all the time
yeah you know what it is you're always
if you got it flaunted that's what I say
but you wanted to actually come in here
and talk about MILF Manor like I haven't
seen that [__] no I just said if you
watched it because oh yeah crazy I
watched MILF Manor bro dude I the second
up is really good deals dude even like I
said this on stream but it's like
PornHub at least slaps a step in front
of the mom you know what I mean like
these [__] were like YOLO no
it's incest City they're not [__]
their moms but that's like okay but they
are rooming with their mom who's gonna
fall so the entire premise but like
reality television and I'm like I have a
doctorate in this okay I watch a lot of
realities are you serious I watch a lot
of reality TV what's your favorite
reality show
um
I'm currently watching kid nation on
stream right now I love like
specifically oh you're watching early
2000s era reality television because it
like it's a bygone era hell yeah second
episode an eight-year-old literally goes
are they going to hang the chicken like
they hang Saddam like it's like [__]
like that that I just you know insane
okay all right says a lot about America
I'm in America as you know I wasn't in
the country while this [__] was
happening so like I love I'm fascinated
about it
reality TV is about conflict right it's
about deflection it's about misdirection
so like the entire purpose of MILF Manor
is literally the well they won't the
MILF Manor oh I like milk will they
won't they about incest
the will they won't they obviously
they're not gonna [__] with their moms
like everybody knows that but like
that's the that is going to be the
challenge is that like they're going to
constantly put their moms and the sons
in positions where it's like very
awkward because the moms are [__]
horny the sons are kind of horny too and
like then the horny moms are like doing
these like blindfolded challenges like
fondling everyone's [__] to see which
one is your son's like yeah that you're
right actually I see what you're saying
now like that's insane that's just
incest the first episode they're like
okay y'all gotta feel you're gonna feel
everybody shirtless like oh there's okay
but they're not their son's not going to
be there right and they're like and you
have to identify which one's your son
yeah I was like whoa adult interest I'm
into it though yeah no it's freak [__]
and I love it dude because you know
we're all we're all just like degenerate
perverts at this point [__] it just have
fun with it
um I don't know what you just sent me in
Discord AV
oh here yeah here it is this is the
lineup so each mom goes and has to
fondle each one one by one yeah so what
I was saying though is because it's not
easy to find a MILF and a son they both
agree to be on the show and the Suns
want to [__] with older ladies so like
this is not the best this is not the
cream of the crop like a lot of these
women and kids are like unfuckable and
and not that I'm the authority on that
I'm just saying like there's this one
kid he looks like he's 16. I think this
is him yeah the 20 year old no one of
those moms wants to [__] that kid I
guarantee you dude yeah I mean you're
you'd be a literal pedophile yeah I
think like the main crazy The Guiding
motivator for everyone here is the
universal uh currency that we all care
about Cloud I think that's like cloud is
what's motivating these people
yeah because usually on reality shows
like if you watch The Bachelor all the
guys are like
[__] oh my why did I just say that
I was gonna say ridiculously [__] I
was meaning to say ridiculously yeah
we're starting off early today where's
the skill switch Dan
let's go you didn't even finish it you
didn't even know I stopped myself I
stopped myself that's not I meant to say
ridiculously jacked that was such an
honest moment for you you literally went
well why did I like it sometimes it's
just like some [__] just comes out of
your mouth you're like what the [__] I'm
glad I caught myself and was able to
edit edit edit myself you know it was it
was funny though it's like growth oh
yeah maturity Aiden Ross stop jerking
off yes found uh you know the light of
Allah wait wait wait hold on I gotta I
want to ask you truly about finding a
lot but hold on so this is the kid that
this kid is apparently 20. yeah his mom
is the craziest person there by the way
she tried to [__] do it on the first
night yeah she's like I'm so horny she's
so wild she's like yeah I need a [__] oh
let's go in the second episode she has a
freak out because the guy she's
interested is Mexican he's speaking
Spanish okay spoilers I haven't watched
it I'm watching second episode and go
yeah I know I know I came here to talk
about MILF manner so let's talk shop
adult incest
but who's I mean no offense he just
looks like a child
what's your argument
what's your argument yeah what's your
argument right there's no problem I know
who loves this show that is yeah frager
hates it because like three of his
Ex-Wives are on it
I ever made my point but yeah if you
watch The Bachelor everybody's like
insanely jacked like roided out and then
a lot of these guys just have like
normal bodies yeah it's gonna be hard to
find like like a like a sexy dude and
also like a sexy mom exactly and they're
both like willing yeah yeah but there it
is
yeah they did it they did it um this is
actually a joke from 30 Rock from like
15 years ago MILF Banner yeah wait yeah
oh yeah they call it MILF Manor they
call it MILF Island and I mean they they
go way harder like they make the kids
like actual like eight-year-olds and on
it but it's such it's such good comedy
writing man that's great comedy writing
that's undefeated do you do you think
the creators of this show are
referencing that or did they just not
they're just because like that yeah
because that is uh that is a joke about
the depravity of of reality TV right and
like Alec Baldwin's character you know
going to insane lengths including
pedophilia to like you know do
incredible network television right TLC
baby and then finally learning yeah are
we learning yet yeah we're learning that
incest is wincest
a dilf
that's my man all right so saying that
with a mullet in this hat on
sure that's right baby I've been trying
to um get a hold of Aiden Ross I know
you're in touch with him he sent me his
address he stopped he has stopped
responding to my textbook I think he
knows he hates me now he's like because
you haven't found oh well you are you
are you have found the light of Allah
well I yeah my starting point is with
the light of Allah but like but like he
I don't think he's like becoming Muslim
or anything I think he's just like
learning all the
wrong things I guess about Islam which
is like hyper westernized in a weird way
um you know there's just like every
every religion there's some there's good
and there's bad you know it's all about
your personal interpretation your
personal journey I don't have an issue
with that but no it all adds up okay
Tate went to converted right yeah
converts are a little wild though and
every born-agains are the worst yeah
we call them reverts because everyone is
technically Muslim so you're just like
is that what you're all born again and
yeah revert yeah that's fire kind of
it's almost like
I like how it's almost like blaming the
person
no no it's very understanding it is
Islam is uh yeah it's uh you reverting
that means like yeah you're you're
finding you know you're finding your
path again you're straight away from it
kind of thing okay okay okay
uh anyway so Aiden he's a SIM for Tate
we know that he shaved his head now he's
talking about how uh he had he's sworn
off jerking off because it's poison for
his mind he says alcohol alcohol is
poison for the mind and all this [__]
and now it's I'm starting to put it
together he come out against hot tub
streams and I'm starting to think that
this man might be reverted no I well I
mean it's not real like that's the thing
right but I do think that there is uh in
a weird way it's just like trendy I
guess like people kind of in a weird way
find because like tradcat [__] was like
popping
so now it's like what's the real Trad
cath religion it's not Catholicism the
pope is like gay now you know what I
mean like right you're not gonna see the
[__] mola out there being like yeah
you know
that's the real one in the eyes of the
Western World which by the way Islam is
not a monolith it's a much more complex
situation it's a much more complex
conversation there are billions of uh
Believers that that range from a varying
degree of like Progressive values all
the way to like the fundamentalists
all that stuff is is super complicated
but
um as far as
as far as like the Western understanding
of Monolithic Islam uh in the aftermath
of the war on terror has always been
that like these are the real religious
guys you know what I mean they're not
embarrassed they they do the misogyny
they do all the stuff that we should be
doing so like they see it as like the
real the final actual like real
fundamentalist old school Traders
awesome that's why like Taliban and Tate
have made like a love connection and I
think that's really special yeah it's
just it's all
everyone turns into an American liberal
at the end of the day cultural
imperialism is too powerful American
culture is is too captivating that's why
you got you got the [__] you got
[__] wearing like Nike Slides
you know who were living in a [__]
cave who came from uh you know the
mountains of Pakistan
talking about like being groupers on
Twitter like you should not know that my
man what the [__] like how did you jump
11 steps and become like and behave like
a kid from Ohio who's just like a
radicalized teenager because like he was
isolated and and went on the wrong
civilization
George Soros I think
here by the way uh Arab world news you
remember our friend in the news world
yeah yeah so he has an updated update
this didn't get claimed right
uh I I didn't I didn't test that there's
music wait what
I don't know I occasionally check in on
him just to see what he's up to and this
was one of his latest videos and I
actually had quite a few views oh no
this guy actually died yeah I know it
has passed away wait I don't know who's
Reggie groover
I don't know who it is
a YouTuber
that is sad and the work is
I'm glad Airborne News is here to you
anywhere
was he associated with the anime or was
his name just slick Goku uh I I looked
at his channel and he does seem to have
some uh he does seem to be like an
animation okay so yeah he would make
friends
[Music]
so Arab world news is like a super big
fan of of anime is that what that means
of this kind of very Niche like he's
just he's just watching CJ the
championship for those of you who don't
know
um another incredible anime review
Channel
he just does the news bro you know what
I mean he just covers trending topics
for example and I just saw that that one
had two and a half thousand views that's
way more than usual this one it has even
more of a banger yo his death videos are
actually doing everything for him oh my
God I got even more you think he
realized like oh this this [__] like
people yeah people watch it so we just
gotta hit that you know what I Arab
world news you should become a eulogy
Channel because I think this content is
connecting it seems like it I mean it's
way higher views than do we know who
Randy Gonzalez is you know I don't but
let's learn peace Randy he's a he's a
tick tocker he did a bunch of tick tocks
him and his son oh I see him yeah he he
was only 35 he passive colon cancer oh
[__] Jesus right what the [__] 35 yeah
colonoscopy name dude
stage four colon cancer damn brother
that's not fair at all
yeah well your death was a great benefit
to the Arab world news channel so we
salute you for that
thing was not in vain my friend
I am partnering up with high power
wellness and we're trying to give away
these packages that didn't work to help
people with their health and the main
goal here is to educate you yes to give
you the understanding that is very
important how you fuel your body what
you eat and what you drink and you can't
just listen to the doctors because they
don't give you all the information you
needed I was blessed that I met Gary you
were just reached out to me and he's
helping me get through this process so
that's our main goal here is to educate
people that know what to feed your body
the correct way
not just before after the cancer
I think during during patience
that want to live the correct way of
life
he predicted his death in the last video
I think my man my man is cancer dog what
the [__] he's like Thomas over here he's
like these are my these are my final
days I just want to say goodbye
yo this dude predicted his death that's
wild
erness coming to you baby this is my
video that I'm doing for my symptoms
people wanted to know how did I find out
I had colon cancer and what was my
symptoms right well it's really easy and
it's really simple to tell you my
symptoms it was just a lot of um where's
the Arab world news part of this video
yeah usually he tries in by now this man
just re-uploaded his content and that
was his best yeah this wild thing to do
for for people on YouTube to just like
you know
to just post about like content creators
who passed away I mean I I like the
niche I think he should follow it if I
ever die he would be [__] everyone
would be watching that all of our line
is bust away
Ethan was a great man too many frozen
pizza now
I said no the last time I had frozen
pizza was with you okay bud yeah yeah
dude you're you're doing great you're
doing great are you you're still working
out you're still you're still dieting
yeah I'm doing pretty good still
doing pretty good
I've been not like I need to get back
like on the full dedication but I'm like
half dedicated so I'm not I'm still at
my lowest ever I'm not gaining weight I
just need to get back on Focus yeah
um The New York Times the daily today
was talking about childhood obesity and
how's the epidemic in in the country and
like what apparently like [__]
doctors are now literally telling
children that they should get bariatric
surgery which is wild so my dad got it
my brother got it it's cash bypass they
like cut your stomach basically it hits
yeah they're just straight up like nope
this is like doing that apparently
doctors are now very aggressively trying
to like early on immediately uh suggest
does that work those are good results
Associated man that sounds interesting
with the bariatric surgery yeah but it's
usually seen as like our last resort
which is why I thought it was strange
that they're like immediately hitting
that button well I think in the cases of
like extreme obesity of kids when like
it's really crazy I think like 90 I'm I
may be pulling this out of my ass but
from what I recall it's like 90 percent
morbidly obese for life
yeah yeah no it's not like uh [__] I
forgot the numbers I gotta look into it
more but yeah they it's not people you
know how we have a concept of like oh
that's just baby fat like that's not it
that's what doctors are basically saying
like nope that's not baby fat it doesn't
go away you're just like OB your child
is obese and he's going to be an obese
adult and it's also one in five it says
around 55 of obese children go on to be
obese in adolescence around 80 of obese
adolescents will be obese adults
kids loved Hitler yeah so we need to cut
out their stomachs I guess yeah and then
they were apparently doctors are also
prescribing uh the the in there's a
there's a wave of insulin drugs that
people use now
as appetite suppressants I heard it's a
diabetes medicine yeah diabetes
medication
um the problem is I even I talked to my
doctor about this it's like I cut my you
know I I don't eat a normal amount I eat
like less than someone in my size would
be eating normally because I'm very
sedentary and my my metabolism is super
slow
because I drag everything and
um when you get off of it though you
[__] shoot up doesn't like you're you
people gain more weight they say because
your appetite is just like
uncontrollable once you're off of it
right and there's a lot of Nationwide
shortages and stuff so obviously hitting
it Natty is always the best yeah yeah
it's always the best move
um I yeah I've heard a lot about this
drug it's like apparently some people
are calling it like a miracle weight
loss yeah but if you go off
it makes you shed weight or it no it
just shuts off your appetite in your
brain like entirely because your insulin
is like very your insulin uh has a lot
to do with your with your
with your stomach with your weight loss
with your weight gain how you process
food says it works on two naturally
occurring hormones that help control
blood
sugar and are involved in sending
fullness signals to the gut so you
should just take up smoking cigarettes
go P1 agonists are what they're called
they're diabetes drugs uh not cleared by
the way by the FDA for weight loss but I
guess it's going through
It's Going Through official channels to
do that but sounds crazy no they
um
well I guess like uh amphetamines were
originally also used as a weight loss
drug
yeah in the 60s yeah that was more fun
probably the way to lose weight yeah
it's a class two type uh it's a classic
type 2 diabetes drug that only improves
blood sugar control but may also lead to
weight loss
well I was reading that like as on
average people were losing 30 of their
way over like two months
yeah this is what I say all the time
weight loss is literally it's just I
mean everyone who is like a valid
uh educated person that has an opinion
on this matter or has made a YouTube
video on this matter or has written
about this matter will tell you
eighty percent of it is your diet yeah
obviously genetics play a fundamental
role in this as well but like your diet
you can't outwork your diet
hey bro speaking of working out though
yeah Aiden Ross
yeah
um
so I he talked to XTC last night he
thinks I think he's a rightist
I'm worried about him like I wanna I
wanna make sure that he's doing all
right like he's he's he he I see him
like
focusing on the wrong things focusing on
some right things like he's working out
all the time which I really love I love
when people go out and work out and you
know
um improve uh their their their body
improve their health improve their
mentality you know what bro I'm sick of
him he can go [__] just he can just
go rot for with his you know what I mean
like I try to reach out I try to do the
right thing he sends me his address I
say I'm coming he ghosts me it's like
bro if your role model is Tate and you
want to go find uh if you want to go
join the Taliban go for it bro just be
just I'm not going to try to save you
anymore okay well here's the thing
though like he's doing all this right
[__] I think cutting out alcohol is good
it's very healthy okay cool but like
working very healthy to work out every
day and then this [__] still
thinks it's because he stopped nutting
that that's the reason why he's like
improving his life I'm like bro you're
crazy you're doing you're doing all the
right things bro it's not the [__]
it's not the masturbation dummy it's all
the good [__] that you're doing keep up
the good [__] it's just a fact I'm not
opinion
you see this [__] yeah Dana White bought
this [__] powerslap and I think he
should go to jail for this he's this is
not most critical certified so I I
refuse to watch it like
like this [__] is so [__] up
I think Dana White needs to go to jail
because half of these people are gonna
have damage pituitary glands have you
never seen fight like slap fight uh you
know content before no I have but can I
just say
how the [__] is this Tick Tock allowed
to exist but my [__] Tick Tock gets
banned because you're every goddamn day
for hateful misconduct dude yours is
racist bro super racist where you got
three tick tocks taken down this week
too yeah no the tater tots are going
[__] real aggro with it I just I hate
it I feel like there's just like monkeys
on the dial in that in a room like
there's no like real human being wait
hold on what did ours get removed for
love exact same thing
yeah I've been talking to Austin Knox
about it too like it's they're they're
going hard potatoes yeah the tater tots
are going hard on like Andrew Tate's
enemies perceived enemies on their
little Discord that they paid 50 to be a
part of does this look like a fake does
this look fake doesn't look like he hit
him that hard
a lot of times you have to watch the
slow-mo to really see how brutal it is
like
yeah I don't know I could have taken
that hit okay I'm just kidding I'm
willing to bet if you did a tick tock
reacting to this your Tick Tock would
get taken down and this video would be
fine right yeah one million that's
definitely happening so they they're
holding a pool noodle and if they drop
the pool noodle I guess they they've
lost Consciousness or something
the [__] out of it that's it dude this
[__] is so [__] up it's like it's so
slap fights are actually more dangerous
than boxing and MMA because like you're
you're supposed to be unguarded and you
can very easily get concussed well
there's the ones where they go back and
forth like 20 times and there's no
question in my mind
that they're getting brain damaged no
question in my mind I think OG slot
fights are five and five
that's what they should be eliminating
and this is like open time
oh my God
this is insane it is
make sure his brain is still operating
for the second hit my Lord
do you know where you are right now
two one oh dude you're [__] yeah he's
dead look how big dude and by the way I
love this game because like dudes like
this can become professional athletes
you know what I mean yeah like I love
that name another sport where this man
could be a professional athlete uh
Olympic uh I mean it's like
weightlifting probably like [__] there's
like there's like strong man
competitions where they like tow a car
with their teeth or whatever those dudes
always look like that too yeah football
I mean he looks like a linebacker
lineman I mean he I don't think he's got
I don't think he's got legs for it yeah
yeah probably not that guy's wearing
like a 10xl shirt he's just gotta stand
there and Noah I mean dude he's
obviously a mean competitor right
flat
[Applause]
yeah
oh he's dead
wait hold on he died God damn it I'm
trying to find
I'm trying to find uh some of the better
ones here that I've seen where they just
keep slapping and slapping and slapping
sometimes the ladies get in there
oh yeah there's a yeah you know there's
a women's league yeah let's go
oh God
there yes so
you don't want to get hit in the head
um
yeah and here's Dana White and his goons
literally just commentating Dana White's
looking at her like damn I wish I could
slap her like I slap my wife true he's a
good form I gotta take that home yeah
yeah look at her it's awesome I smoke
marijuana so I don't beat my wife and
children yeah
that's Dana White yeah it stayed away
what the [__] with your right hand God
Dana am I the only guy who does steroids
that I don't actually respect
she don't got the reach of my favorite
oh no she gets she gets her good my
favorite part is I gave him 30 seconds
to get
she done yeah she does like um
it should be illegal this is crazy no
there needs to be some but like we're
watching it obviously that's the reason
why they I mean apparently this wasn't
it's not that it's not entertaining it
wasn't seen as a success
um I guess I mean they're still post
dude you're telling me if there was
Gladiators fighting to the death in
Arena people would watch it yeah it
doesn't mean it's not it shouldn't exist
I would watch it exactly for sure and so
like I feel like there needs to be a
reckoning for this kind of [__]
like are you gonna pay for the are you
Dana White you don't even pay for
healthcare supposedly The Dumpling is
like the the OG okay so he's like he's
famous I've seen his like uh I've seen
his videos
I've watched a lot of his videos this
guy is [__] scary as [__] not this
guy this guy but like Dana White doesn't
even pay for his Fighters health
insurance is he going to pay for these
people's brain damage of course not
Vasily also uh he will he is from what I
understand he matches his opponent's
energy like if there's like a small no
he did not he didn't magical energy
there he did not match his energy in
this nuclear usually he's like known for
not going to Super ham I guess this guy
personally disrespected him or something
oh really he goes gentle on the
oh that's he's a sweet guy yeah yeah
he's a dumpling Giant
kind of looks like Jeremy right there
quartering these people are no
quartering wishes he had the facility
knockout of the facility knockout power
dude come on
that's the famous red loser that's the
famous guy yeah
[__] his ass up dude these people
should not be oh that wasn't with his
wrist so that's the other thing that's
like odd about this is that like their
karate chopping each other's faces yeah
I know it's not a slap it's like an open
Palm [__] silly strike yeah dude look
you look at that
look how his hand hit his [__] head
like there was no breaking that at all
oh
okay there's a there's a war going on
here
yeah I've seen this video I've watched
this video
it's like they're not even there anymore
because okay no he's there
he's gonna break his hand
anyway there's so much of it and it's it
frankly
I find it horrific and I think Dana
White is going to hell for this one
already
there's no there is no saving that man
he's definitely
yeah I just I don't know I wanted to
show that to you I'm sure you had seen
it but where's the guy with the [__]
up face that [__] you know you showed
all this but you never showed Ludwig
agrin's chest boxing where he also uh
demonstrated disgusting classless
violence he did this as well Ludwig yeah
shame on you Ludwig oh I saw that yeah
Connor dog Virginia yeah no he's going
to L2 of them yeah [__] teaching the
Next Generation awful awful habits he's
a right-wing guy that guy all right
mogulmail
wait not the okay this video is fine I
wanted to see him getting slapped but
this is the result this dude did a slap
fight he won by the way
oh my God yeah I've never seen anything
like this
a true competitor my friends
uh purse is going to cover his health
care his health for us definitely not no
oh my God no but these are usually like
former Soviet countries so they have
like some level of Health Care already
so I'd even fix that bro
what the [__] get your balls off my face
man
here it is in the making uh
this is the hero that [__] was fire NF
battle this was compelling pure heart he
shows dude
so the one we just saw is the guy on the
right yeah correct yeah yeah yeah look
at his face look at his face by like
that one his face is just like he he
exploding oh my God and so dude this
he's like dude I can't do this much
watch what a badass is he literally like
put turned his head into the hand he's
like
that one that one he starts crying
there's a tear that rolls down his eye
on the left side oh my God yeah so
there's no shots this is permanent brain
damage there's no
this is the head trauma these guys are
going to have c-e-t at like in like two
years whatever former former like Soviet
countries they they gotta they gotta
find something to do you know and I
guess they got this they got [__]
Parkour videos and and you know dash cam
footage there's like this is the entire
Academy of Putin that's true that's fair
dude I love how they slapped the cotton
out of his ear he's not even there look
at him look at there's nothing left in
his eyes
[Applause]
I think what ended up happening is it it
helped him because it's just like
neutralized right all of his nerves he
has permanent nerve damage on the side
of his face right he can't talk anymore
but he's a true competitor now but he
will never feel pain on that side of his
head ever again holy oh someone said
they're speaking in Romanian yeah
like a dick
this guy's just like I can't watch it
anymore can we move on please
I might never want to see someone
slapping another version ever again
he forfeits and this guy wins I mean
that's how it's not quite said yeah you
either forfeit or you get knocked out I
know but like the guy he's a true
competitor at heart dude
you know what I mean
uh yes so they're gonna they're I think
they're both dead now of uh brain
hemorrhages so rest in peace Arab world
news do your thing
[Music]
I've just I've never
I don't know what it is about slaps but
like
it's like when you see a spider on a on
a TV show or something and then you like
start thinking you have a spider it's
the same Vibes when I watch people
getting slapped I feel like I'm getting
slapped a little bit I see weird let's
talk about some because you're an empath
that's on a [__] that is that it you
have empath energy no I'm an empath oh
no
so let's say uh Trump a diamond of
diamond and Silk's funeral now who was I
don't remember diamond and silk what was
their story
two commentators that uh used to open
for Donald Trump uh silk is the one that
doesn't really talk as much and she just
goes uh-huh and Diamond was the one that
did most of the talking
um unfortunately she uh you know Diamond
passed away
I believe that uh they had a show they
didn't have a show on Fox news they had
a show on like some other uh you know
right-wing channels it was Newsmax or oh
and one of those two I want to say yeah
they but they're a commentary Duo
so I guess uh speaking on Saturday North
Carolina Trump uh had a really nice
eulogy for them
they would they be oh so here's what
happened they would routinely open for
Trump and campaign rallies yeah and they
were backers early backers in 2016. and
then they basically leverage that
notoriety to land a regular commentator
role at Fox News but
um because of their routine
coronavirus uh conspiracies they were
spreading on Fox news they were dropped
from Fox News because they're [__]
fake Fox News
um by the way Fox News is fake news
um rhinos they got a job at Newsmax
afterwards uh and and you know and then
she died I think
I believe she might have died of covet
no that was being speculated about
because she got coveted shortly before
and it may be related because kova can
give you heart problems but she she died
of heart failure yeah so you're right
but the reason why I'm mentioning covet
is because what silk did instead was use
this as an opportunity to say
uh that she actually died of the covet
vaccine but she did not want to say that
she had gotten the vaccine which I don't
believe she actually got the vaccine
um so she was saying that diamond got
uh the the vaccine shedding from someone
else who was That
vaccine shedding gave her the same you
know deadly
vaccine dude I love how they they these
people really are even in death yeah
she's like no don't miss beats
secondhand vax kills yeah so here is
Trump's uh eulogizing these two women
that did such great things for him you
can get vaccine shedding but you know
childhood asthma rates do not increase
as a consequence of gas those in your
home don't ever say that because that's
science and science is gay that's true
I've heard that yeah it's okay I'm gonna
Sound by that Hassan
and I don't believe you know they tell
me I said give me a little time because
I have a lot of people waiting for me
back in a place called Palm Beach
Florida
I said give me a little time what do you
think about 15 20 minutes in and out
I said what could take longer this is a
little longer than 15 minutes right
in masterclass I don't believe you know
they told me that giving a you would be
bitching about it that's that's but
that's like Trump at his best he's this
is like the first time I watched Donald
Trump and went he's back
dude he's back wait I heard he's gaining
on Ron DeSantis too dude he pops off
like this three more times it's over Ron
DeSantis does not have a fraction of the
Charisma that Donald Trump has on his
[__] pink guys will go up there and
be like oh yeah eulogies they're so long
am I right and everyone's gonna be like
yeah
what a [__] loser it's the it's the
the meme like you know rizz
like incredible Riz versus sexual
harassment when Trump does it it's
[__]
rizzantis Rhonda stinky yeah not the
sanctimonious that was a mid-ass line
from Trump moved on he's moved on he
realized it didn't say he's stinky bro
say Rhonda's stinky I've been around
them folks he smells fast
he doesn't look it but trust me he
stinks look at him no no no he he you
could say that you'd be like what what
is he what is the santis what is this
nationality yeah looks like a white
[__] to me yeah I mean look at
him he's Italian he's greasy you know
how Italians are you know what I mean
like old school like [__] ethnic it's
awesome ethnic memes like that yeah
so he said he's what Italian and English
yeah he's Italian
he's greasy he's so greasy you know how
those Italians are I'm from New York
I've known them he eats so many
meatballs people he sweats
growing on him
my goal is to get Trump to say Rhonda
stinky at least one time
so much I wanted to like be in the space
I want him to like accidentally hear it
from someone else like one of his
[__] staffers or some [__] watching
me and then and then if he said it it
would stick no no he must be stinky
Rhonda said this it's so much better Mr
Trump please hire me for your campaign
better than sanctimonious yeah I do like
it
um but yeah you said it okay so he went
to This Woman's uh funeral and they were
doing hymns and stuff for three plus
hours
I gotta watch this again and his this is
the first thing he says to complain
about how long it was I don't
celebrating the life of diamond
I believe you know they told me I said
give me a little time because I have a
lot of people waiting for me back in a
place called Palm Beach Florida you know
Palm Beach Florida I'm so important I'm
too important in a beautiful place
unlike this I come here for 20 minutes
Palm Beach maybe you've heard of it I
love that
they said give me a little time what do
you think you'll think oh that 15-20
minutes in and out
I said what could take longer this is a
little longer than 15 minutes right
he's gonna laugh still yeah they're like
yeah [__] yeah
[Music]
diamonds friends and family they're like
yeah yeah right you're right this
[__] funeral is long this Memorial
was way too long bro what the [__] is
that about I need to get home dude
football's on
yeah no he's he's so good I mean that's
like
that is what made Trump so [__] you
know he he gives you permission to be
like ruthless you know right yeah but
the way he does it is funny he's not you
know what I mean like because he's catty
as [__] you know we love that Trump I
welcome you back I'm ready for another
Trump presidency which one of which one
is diamond
Diamond uh here you have a picture on
the left on the left this is diamond
yeah yeah we love Puerto listen Diamond
uh it was nice knowing you a shorter
memorials a little too long wait there's
too long there's more by the way because
the next one is actually even fun oh
yeah okay there's more let me open the
thread again this is my favorite thing
ever yeah this part is really 69.
a little too long wait this video Yeah
play that one
this video this one is insane and after
silk goes on and on about how much she
loves Trump
and all the great times they had
together Trump gets up and says this I
knew Diamond but I didn't know silk at
all I just learned about silk you're
fantastic
whoa there's no way it's women for like
five years if silk died I don't think
I'd go to the memorial frankly at my
busy man Noah's been no he'd be like
Silk we all know Diamond was carrying
you you're the one who kept saying aha
in the background diamond was the one
who talked all the time I loved her you
not so much listen I have to tell you I
think I speak for everybody when I say I
wish you were in the casket but we can't
control those things they're very
special you're very special oh God and
you know the world is lost one of its
brightest stars real star but I see that
we have another star who is equal to but
she stepped up and she is different I'm
serious I thought I knew them both I
didn't I knew I knew Diamond but I
didn't know silk at all I just learned
about silver you're fantastic you're
gonna carry on Beyond
anybody why are they clapping for that
these are her friends and family their
sister I didn't know you existed why are
they Cloud oh they're sisters right I
forget that yeah right well you you can
forget that Trump on the other hand
insane for him to even mention it at her
[__] funeral
[Laughter]
both I didn't I knew I knew Diamond but
I didn't know silk at all I just learned
about silver they've opened for the
countless rallies for him he invited
them to the White House oh here he is
embracing them
I don't know you I'm sure she's a great
woman this is my first time meeting her
this is awesome listen I'm a huge fan
crazy I'm a huge fan of Siegfried I
don't know Roy I've never heard of Roy
before racing Diamond no love for silk
on that one that's that you can
that's true you're right well the top
one he's he's go to the top picture
again
he's oh yeah I see he's looking at
Diamond again yeah right I love how it
might be true
I never knew she was there Diamond why
do you keep bringing this other lady
yeah this ladies
what is she doing here diamond
on the soles of your shoes what's that
uh Paul Simon yeah hold on they should
have played that at her [__] funeral
bro Simon that's another one I'm a huge
fan of Garfunkel I don't know who Simon
is I've never heard of him never heard
all right Garfunkel is the brains behind
that operation
yeah so that was fun uh that was a good
laugh I'm so glad he's back
more to come from president Donald Trump
45 and 47. we are trolling this
thing oh I love that
uh speaking Saturday at a gathering in
North Carolina Trump said uh oh we heard
you watch that yeah yeah so let's move
it on a little bit here but
I so I've been following the Crowder
daily wire stuff but I haven't talked
about it at all we did yeah when it
first popped off right right and then we
debated on whether or not uh the daily
wire is netting 100 billion Revenue oh
yeah yeah so have you stupid bro so it's
come out that actually
Stephen was
pissed because he actually wanted 120
million dollars yeah
and 50 was lowballing yeah he vehemently
denies that though just to be clear it
was never about the money to him never
yeah this is about the love for the game
the racism and not even like his own
personal racism which he claims but also
young conservatives that want to be
racist on The Daily wire Network to bad
precedent yeah punish people for being
yeah he's just he is for labor rights
okay and labor wrongs oh I heard that
people are accusing about being a
socialist yeah Candice Owens yesterday
called that's awesome Crowder a
communist but she's kind of right yeah
because he is kind of advocating for
worker rights right in a way it's like
yo this contract's not fair where's my I
need a fair contract yeah
you know socialist uh benefits benefits
package that allows you to say like the
n-word three times live
like Beetlejuice yeah
yeah there that's a fair and balanced uh
demand demand well here's Ben here let's
see we sent him his term sheet offering
him 50 million dollars over four years
plus a two-year extension for 25 mil
you know basketball player type money
yeah on November 2nd Stephen called up
Jeremy and said I want 30 million
dollars the eyebrows that's what I was
gonna say his eyebrows look huge today
some caterpillars man why is his
eyebrows were not always that big I
think he I think he fills them in why
does it make him look this there's also
the speculation that he has lip fillers
on Tick Tock yeah
a little bit of juice there well how old
is he
he's like our age 42. no uh what shut
the [__] no I think he's in his late 30s
Ben is
[Music]
39.42 I'm 30. I'm not even 32 yet man
yeah bro I meant r as in Ethan no me and
Hassan are in our 30s what are you
talking about I I was referring to you
how old are you Dan I'm 41 I'm a year
younger than that okay oh Jesus Christ
anyway his eyebrows those that ain't
right that is not natural
this guy's doing the um
Steve what's his name Steve Harvey on
his eyebrows you know Steve Harvey has
that insane mustache right he's got
strong I think he's filling it up a
little bit yeah I mean he puts on makeup
for sure okay I don't know who told him
that makes him look good but
somebody said you look distinguished
with fat [__] deep eyebrows yeah it's
like the Anthony Davis approach whatever
I meet you know people who are saying
how long dude you definitely do your
eyebrows what the [__] are you look at
the lips I told you wait now I am yeah
killer thing yeah
not natural Benny boy no way he looks
like that guy yeah he had two yeah no
I'm dating it'll say two years Max what
are you waiting for
for someone who has such a hard stance
on closed borders and like a Hardline
policy on immigration oh he sure is
letting that lip filler migrate okay
Queen
[Music]
October 5th is when we send him his term
sheet offering him 50 million dollars
over four years plus a two-year
extension for 25 minutes no basketball
player type money on November 2nd
Stephen called up Jeremy and said I want
30 million dollars a year and a bunch of
changes to the term sheet I'm not going
to redline the term sheet I'm not going
to edit the term sheet I just want you
to send me a brand new offer on November
6th four days later remember this is
after he's already sounded off he's got
the term sheet he's had it for a month
November 6th was election night you'll
recall if you're a daily wire fan
Stephen Crowder appeared on an election
night coverage everything was very
friendly that was everything was very
challenging everything was great
November 14th or thereabouts
we decided that we couldn't meet his
demands that his demands were not
rational in business terms that he
wanted too much money and all the rest
of it so we let him know you know no
hard feelings we're still friends just
like we do in every contract negotiation
as Tim Poole said on his show last night
and we've had contract negotiations with
Tim and we disagreed and went our
separate ways and we still liked him Tim
still likes us and I'm trying to hire
Tim yeah that got kind of revealed in
all of this too and that really did blow
my mind because it's like what listen
you know it's not like I hold them in
high regard but Tim Poole seems below
even them I mean you know they hired
Candace Owen bro absolutely yeah but she
has a utility you know what I mean I
guess uh Tim Poole is just white he has
a utility too he's liberal he's their
first time
their first left-wing host he he is uh
an important liberal voice uh to add in
the conversation
who else can come up with incredibly
liberal ideas like uh 50 state sweep for
Donald Trump yeah and everyone should
own a new Pelosi's husband is a gay uh
has a gay sexual intercourse with uh
David de Pepe
I believe an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own a nuclear
warhead that opinion my friend is worth
50 million dollars and not a cent less
bag of turret you know flaming turd bag
I just I can't get over how much money
these [__] I just like oh
you're right this grift really does pay
it does and now like daily wires almost
like they're sucking them all up like
they're trying to monopolize
right yeah which is of course the free
market obviously obviously obviously
when there's no competition but what's
interesting is both Tim and Crowder said
whatever you're insanely uh lucrative
deal is not enough for us
like yeah because they look to like I
think they all look at like Alex Jones
and stuff and see that there are so many
suckers that are willing to pay you
that have a lot of disposable income and
just want to hear things that they
already agree with
and um no matter what happens like
you're gonna have a you're gonna
generate a lot of Revenue
also you know what actually this is
something I say about myself uh so maybe
they have the same approach
like I don't give a [__] about making 50
million dollars uh in over the course of
four years when the amount of money I
make already is more than enough you
know what I mean I there's no my
lifestyle is not going to genuinely
change from how much money I'm making
Now versus 50 million dollars because
like
I don't even have free time to do all
the other stuff like I already do what I
enjoy so maybe they they're like yeah
I'd rather keep making a couple million
a year and and you know do the racism
without any sort of editorial control
rather than go under the daily wire
umbrella and have like some level of
editorial control and have to do like ad
reads and [__] what do you think about
this
and why why obviously I don't care if
people get lip filler but why is it
interesting if Ben Shapiro got lip
filler
well he he he
presents himself as this like Orthodox
and I mean that as like a like a double
entender almost you know what I mean
he's like a very conservative man right
he's yeah he's already no he's he's
Orthodox Jew but also like he's an
orthodox man you know what I mean like
uh it's it's not necessarily you know
Trad values to to care about your image
to that degree to like get
this aesthetic you know plastic surgery
thing done yeah and he you know just
recently there was like a video of him
daily wire put out a thing where it's
like let's make Ben Shapiro react to
cringe uh tick tocks of uh Thanksgiving
wasn't Thanksgiving yeah something like
that or whatever and you know he's a
very judgmental of young people that
look
that don't conform to uh traditional
Beauty Norms uh uh would since when are
Men supposed to have big plump beautiful
kissables [__] dude yeah what are you
gonna use those big beautiful lips for
Ben no sorry beautiful
I love that Peterson November 14th
they're about to be told Steven that we
couldn't meet his demands
fast forward another month December 12th
he registered the site stop big con oh
hey that's when he registered it oh
remember October 5th is when he received
the terms November 14th is when we said
we could not meet his demands December
12th is when he registered stop VidCon
because he knew that three days later he
was going to be announcing that he was
leaving the blaze he needed a plan and
attacking us was the plan
December 15th he announced he was
leaving The Blaze
a month after that he texted Jeremy in
Friendly fashion to ask if they could
talk
on January 9th he called Jeremy and
proceeded to tape him without permission
that was [__] the fact that he
recorded their call before there was any
like contention is super okay sneaky
sneaky I mean who would have thought
that these guys who are like
disseminating [__] propaganda would
be [__] to one another you know I
mean I personally would never invite
someone onto my show and pull a trick
like that on them
what if Crowder were to call into this
show I would never pull yeah it would be
in total good faith
I keep it real with Crowder yeah
yeah maybe he got that from you actually
the old Switcher
that's awesome yeah um no he's a piece
of [__] though I actually think that the
daily wire
as much as they're all scumbags Crowder
was like far away in the wrong in this
situation it's like crazy that's my in a
weird way I see both sides of the
argument
yeah
a little bit well I see Crowder's
perspective because like I made a joke
about this already but like it's the
daily wire is giving him 50 mil because
he does like
pretty much he says the n-word the long
way you know what I mean okay so like
yeah you're hiring me to be racist and
get banned so that I can like you see
his point yeah you're hiring if you're
hiring me to be racist then I'm going to
be raised and get banned but so if you
understand that a part of my Revenue
driving mechanism involves me getting
banned off YouTube so I can drive more
people over to the paywalled racism the
only Clans if you will then and and you
appreciate I that I do that and Jeremy
boring did literally say like I love
that you do the paywall racism stuff the
piss off YouTube segment it's such a big
I love that it's a great segment like
we're such big fans of that here at the
daily wire
um then yeah like let it that that's his
point it's like punishing I made this
joke but like it's like punishing Steph
Curry for you know shooting
three-pointers right like that's why he
has the contract that he had they would
have been like okay we'll we can remove
this but if we lower your pay
well yeah it didn't even get to that
point well that's you're right like
Stephen Crowder absolutely is using this
to launch the thing is like an email
list for himself that's for sure what
they were friends they were they were
negotiating in good faith you know what
I mean like he didn't have to accept the
deal Steven was not Steven was not right
they thought he was I hate to agree with
Ben Shapiro here uh daddy daddy eyebrow
but
yeah no I I I'm team support 100 I think
that daily wire guys like they're
correct on their assessment that like
Steven Crowder just wanted to make a big
bang
here and he just like threw away their
relationship their friendship
cast it aside for like a little bit of
Internet clout for a brief moment so is
this actually benefiting Crowder like
are his is the is there an audience
being fractured here at all there's
people they don't care do you think I I
I was watch like I watched him on Tim
Poole last night and I checked out his
videos and the daily wire I would say
there's it there's a split going on in
like the conservative Community honestly
my feeling is it seems like it's leaning
a little bit towards Crowder yeah what
yeah yeah because the internet because
the internet I mean come on what
Ethan they're [__] stupid like
everyone is stupid we're all [__]
dumb but you're like extra dumb if
you're the type of person who's like
you're right you know the the 14 year
old trains teenager is running Society
you know what I mean like that if that's
your [__] thing that you believe and
if you're an even Crowder fan like
that's the type of [__] you believe
you're extra dumb so of course you're
gonna [__] think Stephen Crowder is
just like
exactly so they think he's doing this
for free speech exactly no he keeps
insisting it's not about the money and
there's actually a clip coming it's not
about the money you're right now you get
120 million right well he he claimed
here's the thing he says there was never
a counteroffer that that's [__] the
120 million dollar thing however in the
Tim pool interview and this is in the
dock if you want to pull this up because
it's actually a pretty funny moment he
kind of [__] up
and basically lets out that his agent
may have sent a counteroffer and that's
probably what they're all talking about
but like as he's saying it realizes that
he's [__] upset and changes the
subject like immediately here let's take
a look
I'm I'm on your side on this one
everybody can know my bias the reason
that really bothered me is because I run
a company I know how much money we make
and there are people who assume that
Revenue equals money in your pocket
profit and it's like no no if they're
giving him 50 million dollars it sounds
so wonderful I'm assuming you're dumb
yeah I'm sure Tim's overhead is crazy
that's the other aspect of all this he
keeps saying he's like it's not about
the money but also the amount they offer
me is so insulting because they
obviously it's way too low bro as if
like it's 12 and a half million dollars
a year he runs a [__] YouTube channel
like it's not that different yeah like
there's operational costs of like paying
his uh you know racism producers yeah on
like newer versions of bigotry like
older versions of bigotry I guess Man is
dead but like other than that you
already have the cameras you already
have everything like those are those are
costs that you already put into your
business like a trailer and it's like
well that's Tim pool right and he was
bitching about that too I'm talking
about Crowder but yeah I mean he has a
very like he has staff he has a set he's
got the cameras
you know the show isn't that complicated
it's a three camera show or whatever
it's like [__] which is the worst
part about this is like I stream
I stream minimum eight hours a day seven
days a week sometimes I take uh you know
Sundays off every once in a while okay
these [__] are complaining
about four hours of content for 12.5
million dollars four hours of content a
week man that's four hours are you
insane that's sweet deal it's like
that's nuts that's nuts odd dude you
don't understand the amount of research
that we have to do to find new slurs
that's taking up 10 hours every day we
have our race scientists in the
laboratory yeah they're cooking 24 hours
a day yeah but even if you assume he has
like a dozen employees that he's paying
like handsome salaries to which I doubt
which I doubt but like let's just assume
that he's paying them well and he's got
like a dozen of them we're still he's
still walking home each year with like
six or seven million dollars in his
pocket it's not enough you know what
about taxes you think about that I I
hadn't thought of that you're right I
hadn't thought about the theft that
occurred okay so here it is by the way
how dead inside does he look like I'm
just gonna be real this man
there's nothing there
well Candace seems to think she knows
why but we'll get to that they're
they're treating the audience like
they're dumb again well I don't know a
lot of people don't nobody nobody don't
understand this people don't understand
because they're assuming that you won't
go into research look 50 million
basketball money versus 12 million if if
let's say Marvel says I don't know the
new Thor movie is 200 million dollars is
that Hemsworth's salary it's that simple
of an analogy yeah but the issue here
and I'll let Jill kind of talk about
that more the the issue here is like I
think that these people at Daily wire
they've said that they're very business
savvy they're running a business so are
they very business savvy
um and no are they dumb and don't know
that 12.5 million dollars a year for an
entire production house is what we're
actually looking at or bro shut the [__]
up like no you think that people are
dumb if you're trying to convince people
that that's not enough money to put
together a YouTube Production Studio
right and again and again he keeps
saying it's not about the money
but then he keeps coming back to it's
insulting 12 and a half million dollars
are you kidding me it just sucks because
like crazy if you're if that's the value
that you're going to be generating for a
corporation you absolutely deserve to
demand that okay I talk about this with
like basketball player salaries all the
time people oftentimes forget that like
players that get you know 30 million
dollar contracts are actually still
having their Surplus labor value
extracted by billionaires who own the
[__] team who cannot throw a
basketball okay who cannot dribble so
like but I just don't believe that he is
generating I agree 12.5 million dollars
worth of Revenue a year for the daily
wire I just don't like it's impossible
that's what doesn't make sense in my
mind there's no way especially after the
expenses because it's not even on
YouTube they have their own
infrastructure so they're paying like to
have the servers to host this content
yeah so at a fundamental level I
understand the argument that he's trying
to make it's just that like his output
that we're talking about in the
circumstances just like being a [__]
piece of [__] hate Monger you know what
I mean yeah it's weird
are they lying when they say it's
basketball money and 50 million dollars
I think Candace owns at one point got up
to like 140 or something I don't I don't
know you said you wanted 30 million a
year or 140 and the only reason people
people know that's not true and you've
seen the transcript you ever see me once
say hey it's about more money there was
never an offer so that it's not enough
money you literally just you're
literally saying they're not giving me
enough money yeah to do my my uh super
lab but again production it doesn't
require look we found out when When
Donald Trump was like making arguments
uh that just did not make any sense
whatsoever but people were still
listening that like you don't actually
have to have a consistent uh you know
line of thought here you just need to be
on the team and Stephen Crowder is on
the team of I am more racist than the
daily wire I'm a you know bold truth
teller and the daily wire is rhinos
they're fake
which is why people don't even
understand that immediate contradiction
like that's that's immediately he
contradicted himself he's like I we need
more money for this production it's of
expensive production and then turn
around and said it's not about the money
like what the [__] do you think our
production is bigger or smaller than
Crowders I think it's on the same level
if not if ours might be bigger yeah I
think it might be bigger yeah we put out
more content than him how many employees
do we have I don't even think he needs
full-time employees he doesn't want to
show [__] week we have close to a
dozen I mean what there's like 10 of us
here and then uh you and Eli's 12. and
then we and then we have a couple people
help with the socials as well okay so
let me think here would it be wise to
give a a uh estimate on our the cost of
doing business here I mean that's
totally your prerogative if you want to
share that information I have no clue so
we have 12 employees I think I can
estimate the salary on average
we're gonna put in like our mortgage on
the building
and all that kind of stuff also more
expensive
because you're in Los Angeles where's he
shoot out of Austin Austin which is
still expensive but like ain't no
[__] way is his uh is his real estate
uh you know his his mortgage that
expensive I would say we're probably
looking at about 1.5 million dollars per
year overhead yeah maybe maybe a little
bit more I I would guess around this
thing yeah
and so if I'm getting 12.5 million or 12
million dollars a year that's like
a drop in the bucket and also a tax
deduction obviously so it's not like
coming out of your pocket necessarily
so I don't think he spends that much on
production probably way less no I agree
I mean they they occasionally do like uh
sketches and stuff but 99 of the time
they're just sitting in on their set you
know their sketches are all like just
wearing some outfit and doing some race
of [__] like right pretty much it they
don't go out
you don't understand
is there racism insurance I mean we need
to invent that you have you know
liability insurance you even have
umbrella insurance I guess you get sued
yeah I mean I'm sure a lot of these a
lot of these guys do have to take like
fat retainers on like a legal team
because they're
they're both having to defend themselves
regularly but also they do like
offensive legal moves all the time like
Jeremy boring mentioned that in his
video where he says like well that's you
know this is a very expensive business
like we gotta constantly sue the the
federal government we gotta Sue like and
that's something that they do they
weaponize the a team of lawyers that
they have on retainer against platforms
like YouTube Rumble does this [__] all
the time too like they all have like fat
uh they have the worst lawyers known to
man these guys are not supposed to win
any of their cases they lose all the
time but uh the point is to like
you know make work for them and make it
seem like their their dollars are being
spent wisely and getting yeah getting
sign ups on the mug club and [__] like
what was it last year Crowder was suing
YouTube whatever happened to that that
he never did that right it's just like
why yeah but um actually I didn't I
didn't include our legal fees that would
that would put us back well yeah I guess
I don't know if that's fair to include
that's the cost of doing business yeah
you could I don't know how many people
are suing him currently after I said
look it's a non-starter if you don't
change these these terms and please tell
them that you're not doing this for
other people there was never anything
after that whereas of course the
non-starter is I'm not gonna I can't do
five libraries because we do commercials
I just want to ask one specific question
because a lot of people are bringing
this up and they're accusing you guys of
only exposing them after they turn
America Florida
that's a [__] shirt bro
no thanks
down your counter offer is that true or
can you add more information to that
yeah I don't know why they're saying the
time whatever anyway
um I what part I I missed the the part
that was literally I think you just cut
it off literally turned it off right as
you were saying okay okay there's a long
just say wheelhouse I'm I'm on your side
on this one everybody can know my bias
basketball money
production house dead make America
Florida guy
the timeline that he kind of gave was
completely inaccurate yeah there was
never there was never any counter offer
from us what Stephen said was basically
look guys these are the terms that we
have a problem with right and if this I
don't care what the contract says Dollar
Wise if these terms are in there that's
bad and you need to start again this has
to be pulled out so there was no counter
offer because I'm seeing a lot a lot of
you guys say there's the agent the agent
I think my agent the first they sent
this term sheet Adrian said well if
you're talking about 100 ownership by
the way in perpetuity forever meaning
and it's a six-year contract with no
option to negotiate they have an option
to extend for two years six years locked
in at that rate and again right how do
you penalize someone for money that they
don't make yeah they're not going to
lose money on you being yeah no I get
that I'm a special situation
and then he stops himself he's like oh
the agent the Asian probably might have
asked the little six-year contract right
you're locked in perfect yeah no we did
he did go back yeah yeah he did 100 did
yeah so he's full of [__]
because he said it over and over again
that there was no it was never about the
money there was no counteroffer but I
don't think they asked him directly and
he's like well my Asian
does one of those dude so Candace Owen
who will never be top on crazy response
and I guess she went [__] nuts on him
which I love obviously yeah she first
implied that he was like gay I think
yeah that's that's in there she first
was like oh bless his heart you know you
should all pray for Stephen he's going
through a lot right now he apparently
has a video of him sucking dick or
something what oh my God she's getting
ready to drop the receipts I mean if
she's got I'll die I I will perish can
you imagine dude that'd be awesome
over the weekend I was given a lot more
information regarding Stephen Crowder a
lot more background information
regarding what could have possibly led
to this moment and
not to my surprise at all obviously this
really doesn't have anything to do with
the daily wire and his actions are a
symptom of much something much larger
and I want to choose my words very
carefully here because I'm Not Angry
Anymore
Stephen has a lot going on I guess it's
the best way to say it he has a lot
going on and that should be clear
because people don't do stuff like this
if there's not a lot going on in real
life
oh she's the worst she is like so vile
every single person involved in this is
such a piece of [__] and I love it it's
so fun I'm so happy to be on the outside
looking at how like conniving and how
how shitty they are just awful human
awesome it's so fun for me yeah but the
thing is um I'm really surprised because
like the daily wire has been going on an
all-out like infowar against Crowder and
somehow he's still still looking good I
find that interesting because you're
forgetting
it's a race to the bottom
whoever is like dumber and and more
openly racist
dog whistles are for the intellectuals
you know save that that's for the birds
what do you go to college are you
[__] nerd you're gonna you can tell
me about how like systemic racism is
actually a Marxist conspiracy no just
literally be like black people are
inferior that's what they want God okay
so that is precisely the reason why
Stephen Crowder is always going to uh
have a have an upper hand in this
argument
in the room
there it is let's see what candy has to
say since these things are actions of
individuals that are perhaps acting out
of desperation you have to dig deeper
you have to look deeper to fully
understand the picture of why somebody
might do that and it's certainly not
because somebody is upset with a 50
million dollar contract and because I
now am more aware of certain information
yeah so he got a video of him sucking
dick no I don't think exactly but I
think she's like implying that he might
be you know
I don't know I watched this and I
thought oh [__] like
maybe she got she got the documents
right on on something
maybe like uh some word of mouth but not
like I don't think there's a video she's
like yo someone calls her it's like yo I
really need to talk to you about Crowder
so he's gay yeah he's like oh but like
how did you not know that already how
did you not know that already he's gay
it's homophobic not to know all right
that's true rather than being angry I
would like to implore my audience and
everybody that isn't paying attention
this situation not to condemn him but to
pray for him pray for him sometimes
people need a prayer sometimes people
need a scripture Stephen purports to be
a Christian and I believe that or maybe
he cheated on his wife or something lean
into his face yeah that'd be awesome
that could it could be with a dude that
too I think yeah I think if Stephen
Crowder cheats on his wife like it's
probably with the man he was smoking
meth in a motel room with a gay
prostitute I don't think he's a meth guy
his little heart would give out that's
true he doesn't have the heart to do
what drugs can he do with a bad heart I
don't [__] know but oh
yeah not a lot of good ones probably no
uppers no uppers so what's left opiates
yeah I mean but this this did it's
giving prey the gay away like that's
what I got out of this like it was like
pray for him bless his heart bless your
heart bless his gay
bless this man's weak little gay heart
pray that I keep ticking there boy so it
can live to touch another a lot of baby
pointed this out but like a lot of
conservatives do uh abuse bars like they
do Xanax
because it slows it down gives it a
break yeah right
um straight there's a little bit left in
here and uh I'm certain that in the near
future more information will come out I
do not think it is my place to say more
than that well probably
I am unsure at this moment if if it is
my place to say more than that a little
bit she reserves the right yeah
you should be set it's not time for me
to release this stuff in the [__] T
sis I mean it just sucks because like if
this was a real big [__] I think the
daily wire would launch the nuke on them
but like they let Candace do it because
Candace is like she's like the lower
wrong she says like unhinged [__] on a
daily basis attack dog yeah for them we
have credible evidence that Stephen
Crowder is a homosexual and then she
turned around and said he's a communist
the next day like your follow-up was
weak man just give us the goods yeah
just the juice come on Candace Owen
responds to the Tim pool appearance the
next day
pointing out he basically accidentally
admitted to ask him for 120 120. I saw
that too candy I saw the same thing whoa
she like that's kind of like a
it's a bathrobe this doesn't look like
clothing like this you got a bathroom on
you know in that last video I was
admiring her outfit and I noticed the
chat was too
um oh is she popping off she was popping
a little bit she had a good outfit this
one this one works I mean this one's
fine Olivia thought it looks like a robe
someone's stylish go ahead Olivia it
definitely looks like a robe if it's a
shirt it's a it's a shirt okay okay
she's a horrible mom
horrible monster piece of [__] an attack
dog for white supremacists you know he
is the black voice of of white supremacy
but you know she is kind of stylish
she's very pretty
you know oh yeah you can't get over the
things she says it's just I can't that's
what's kind of special about her I
cannot see her as like uh I cannot
attribute any further positive values to
her baby
chill then he's so [__] beautiful
chill the [__] out bro
you don't think you can save her son I
have the great luxury of coming
if he received this term sheet and he
was just so outraged by the terms and it
was completely a non-starter why did he
come back to the Daily wire with a 120
million dollar offer and what you'll see
is that he says we never did that and
then he very quickly says maybe my agent
or manager did do that and then change
the subject which is maybe my agent did
do that is essentially you saying yeah
that happened we countered take a listen
to Stephen Crowder thank you so there
was no counter offer because I'm seeing
a lot Candace does not get a lot of
views 44 000. I wonder how much they
paying her probably only 10 million
dollars a year yeah a week wait what the
[__] she doesn't get [__] from views
dude you know there's a gender pay Gap
and a raised pay gap of the daily wire
for sure you need the audit oh yeah
coming a lot of you guys saying there's
the agent the agent I think my agent the
first they sent this term sheet they
said well if you're talking about 100
ownership by the way in perpetuity
forever meaning and it's a six-year
contract with no option to negotiate
they have an opportunity
just totally said that they countered
for two years six years so working at
that rate and again right how do you
penalize someone for money that they
don't make they're not going to lose
money on you being demonetized now I get
that I'm a special situation but they
said this is demanded of everybody
so there you go no no no no absolutely I
think my agent maybe again it was about
whether or not it's going to be
floundering
literally just said you don't lose any
money if I get demonetized yes they do
of course of course they do the like
because they take that revenue and it's
and so they're no longer getting that
revenue and they pay you so yeah they're
losing money that makes total sense like
cheers pretty obvious should be very
obvious to every single person that
essentially what he's saying is Well
maybe my agent yes your agent got back
and said 120 million dollars so it was a
starting conversation you knew that this
was taking place and I don't even I like
I said I'm past anger with the situation
I do feel bad for him because I know
more of what's going on in the
background and I do believe this is a
man that is spiraling but yes I love
that yeah she hit that again I love when
she hits that button oh come on give us
give us the juice if it's spiraling
behind the background I do think it has
to do probably with his marriage falling
apart right I mean what else could it be
yeah okay which would be cool too I'm
down for that for him yeah
he wasn't celibate until marriage and uh
you know
anything bad happening to him I'm down
with yeah sodomy is still sex Stephen
okay even if done with a man are you
sure just saying because I thought you
could I thought sodomy was like uh a
loophole it's a different thing
exactly exactly I didn't know I just I
thought if I if I did the poop hole
loophole with a man it was doubly not a
sin you know that's a big game right man
[Laughter]
maybe just a bit gay it's so important
that we inject truth into this and you
cannot say that you were so offended by
a contract so offended so mortally
wounded by the cons of a contract that
your agent as if you are too you guys
don't speak she's right went back and
said okay 120 million and then that
you're right after that daily wire never
came back with any other term sheet it
was never a contract whatsoever and then
the second thing which I thought was
borderline delusional was him liking
himself to James O'Keefe when people are
rightfully outraged that irrespective of
what you thought about
the great uh civil rights leader of
veritas yeah project veritas's very own
you know
when is he joining daily wire I wonder
oh God you know he's got the big ass
contract pending gee you would record
your friends he's in trouble and then
release didn't he like
being investigated uh he is I hope he
goes to jail okay God that'd be so sick
maybe it's a lawsuit or something I
think he might be a business in trouble
he might be one of the only dudes on the
right of like the right wing popularity
that's as as disgusting as candy
um September a jury ruled against
project yeah they got sued
uh it was only for well I say only but
120 000 you're in trouble probably
enough enough to sink them Crowder
[__] drops that kind of money on the
growth yeah that's nothing
chump change contents of the
conversation chopped up so people can't
discern the context whatsoever here's
what he had to say about that if you had
the ability let me read the comments
let's see what Candace hope you see this
at the age of six to seven my mom took
me to us what the [__] are you talking
about dude can we stick to the goddamn
topic
30 minutes how is this a podcast no
wonder no one watched it 30 Minute
Podcast no cheers I don't think it's the
whole thing right it says episode 79. oh
I guess it is the whole maybe part of
it's paywalled on uh on daily Wire yeah
she's like I will get super races behind
the paywall yeah don't worry chicken you
know tune in for that one eight dollars
a month right
oh [__] I mean we do that at fear end as
well we I saw that so when I was on they
hit me with the if you want to finish
this podcast you got to pay you got to
go on patreon yeah and I was like oh
[__] we should do that yeah that's how
we do it we do we we shoot a one one
take episode good and then we cut it in
half and then we get a real episode yeah
oh [__] let me finish
that's why I also like that's why I also
pair it with like an appearance on the
twitch stream too like I wanna I wanna
max out on like uh the value to the
to the content creator who's coming on
you know what I mean they get like the
the ultimate boost that way I wonder if
we could do like one and then they come
on and they [__] all over my production
listen at least it was paywall do you
know what I mean they [__] on all my
production on the twitch stream they go
oh wow this sucks nobody cares about
these things that you're watching on the
production I thought come on it was
funny I started my memory stream talking
about what I did in the morning oh yeah
yeah oh yeah like Hassan yeah I was like
boring no one cares I said I woke up
this morning I had eggs
you know
somebody said you want to hear Ethan say
the by uh the b word pay 5.99. oh what's
the b word oh you know
um resolution
air strikes he anyway
where are we but I was thinking maybe we
should do that like a members only
segments because not to cut like the
whole app but just be like hey members
we're gonna do one extra segment where
you know we'll watch the prolapses or
something all right well let's let's
talk about it cheers
like that idea it's like you're just
throwing it out there at random no it
works every time Zach don't listen to
Dan I love it every time I got you yeah
you know what's up
um okay I guess that's about it for now
on that front but I'm waiting for the
tea to drop on crowder yeah speaking of
people who are uh you know living a
double life uh as Queens uh Georgia is a
good Segway nice you know George Santos
my king and queen as a matter of fact
yep depending on whether or not she's in
dragon slaying George Santos look at
this guy man
this guy I don't know how much you guys
know about we haven't talked on the show
before
okay nice graphic wow this is [__]
he says George Santos a lying dumbass no
he's he's a king he's the king he is the
goat you Stan him yeah I stand him I see
what you're saying literally lying yeah
I am completely fascinated by this guy
he is a compulsive pathological liar he
cannot stop himself it's a medical
condition you guys are being ableist it
is
also yeah so this guy he won he won a
seat in Congress and people ended the
New York Times started trying to look
into his background like who is this
young upstart conservative and they
started fact checking his resume like
his school credentials his work
credentials and they've started look uh
slowly find out that every single
[__] thing this guy has ever said
about himself is 100 wrong top to bottom
just not even wrong like a flat out lie
like this guy like lying this guy said
he went to a prestigious uh Horace Mann
school
he's the type of Dude to lie about his
birthday for no reason like like just
[__] that doesn't even give him like an
immediate tangible benefit he lies about
everything and anything he can yeah I
had a friend like this I don't think his
glasses are real I think even this
[__] black kid might be right a big
lie I knew a person like this I had a I
had a good friend that uh that really
was a pathological liar and like you
said he would just lie about [__] that
it's just like it's nobody cares and
everybody knows like everybody knows
you're a pathological liar too at that
point and it's just like you still keep
doing it like what the [__] yeah he
can't stop himself so he he lied about
his high school which I guess is a
prestigious private high school a horse
man School uh they look they contacted
the school that was a lie he obtained a
high school equivalency diploma so he
got a GED yeah so he didn't even I mean
you know whatever no hate but he didn't
even go to high school yeah he claimed
about where he went to college
he claimed he graduated with a degree in
economics and finance from buric Baruch
College yeah
um and but of course he also said he was
a star on the volleyball team that part
is the best he said he was a he was a
volleyball star but he got a knee
surgery and the reason why he said that
was because he wanted the Nassau County
GOP chair Joseph Cairo to like him and
want him to play in their intramural
volleyball team he better be good though
he's not gonna be able to but that's
[__] ins that's like a what benefit
are you getting at that point like why
did you lie about something how tall is
he sane how tall because I think to be
like a pro volleyball player you got to
be like really tall right yeah you gotta
be like super athletic yeah and then he
admitted that he did not graduate from
any institution of Higher Learning uh my
favorite part of the Saga was 9 11. yeah
so here he goes he died about his mom
dying on 9 11. UM the campaign went say
Santos wrote that his mother the first
female executed at a major Financial
executive this 911 Saga is like I mean
it's Larry David it's literally Larry
it's a Larry David plot line like he he
first said his mom died in the [__]
towers and then he and then he he
followed It Up by saying no his mom was
actually uh not in the towers but he was
uh but she was in uh you know downtown
at the time and died years later from
cancer because of the you know the toxic
inhalants from 9 11. then we found out
that his mom wasn't even in [__]
America at the time she was actually in
Brazil at the time during 9 11. awesome
his mom wasn't even in the country
that's some crazy Stolen Valor and she
wasn't working in finance or anything
she was a housekeeper yeah so it's wild
that he just lied about that you know
there's what benefit do you get from
that the fact of lying that your mom
died at 9 11 is awesome but like I see
kind of like there's a paint a picture
of like someone who comes like from a
not a privileged life at all who's
probably deeply insecure with his
Heritage probably
because well you see how people treat
AOC who actually has come a long way on
her own merits and uh you see how people
treat her especially conservatives so
yeah he's insecure about his Beginnings
but the level to which he lies is
absolutely nuts this guy is a
manipulative lying con man his mother
actually uh
uh she uh she filed a visa to return to
the United States
um his mother actually he is a domestic
worker home care nurse yeah and she's
still alive right no uh no she passed
away and I think yeah that's actually if
you go into this in this here I'll just
pull it up so after all of this all this
lying putting it on his campaign site
and stuff
he tweeted this in 2021 December 23rd
this year marks five years since I lost
my best friend and Mentor Mom right so
five years previous to 2021 is not 2001.
she could be [__] but but he could be
lying about her mom dying
like every single part of this is is a
falsehood yeah so you have to assume
that he's probably lying about his mom
even dying his mom's probably alive
right now in Brazil
um speaking of Brazil there's a I mean
first of all let's talk about the
Goldman Sachs thing yes his campaign bio
stated that he worked at Goldman Sachs
and Citigroup but representatives for
both companies told The Times They had
no record of his employment don't know
why you didn't talk about how he lied
about being Jewish by the way oh yeah
like he's weird ones he claimed that he
was a Ukrainian Jew mm-hmm that's
[__] weird that's the Bingo like he
hit literally every [__] you know
notable marker for like liberals living
in Nassau County to be like well maybe
I'll take a look at this guy you know
what I mean wait is he gay yeah so he's
probably straight no no he's actually
gay I'm pretty sure he's seen the video
of him no but I have seen how he
responds to drag queens on Twitter and
that boy is gay
deep knowledge of RuPaul's Drag Race
that like as as gay and Jason as I am
even I don't [__] know like he was
like talking about like you know Season
victories and [__] wow yeah so he pretty
much concocted this like perfect uh
I don't know victim yeah he's a
Ukrainian Jew that like fled Nazi
persecution that was a lie when he
called out on and he said he's Jewish
which is another like that's a Larry
David thing that's another yeah that's
what I'm saying I didn't say I'm Jewish
I said I'm Jewish he is very
It's the funniest thing ever yeah
it's like it's like when Kanye West had
that like impeccable timing the
incredible timing on a joke that like
like you know that makes me feel like
George Santos is literally Larry David
is Larry David Carrick yeah
it's uh no there's uh Ethan just asked
if there's a video of it it's not it was
in a written interview I said he said
that yeah
um he said he's never claimed to be
Jewish he just said he's Jewish
um
I didn't say I'm Jewish I'm Jew and he
also he also I'm like I'm Jewish like he
lies about so many verifiable things
like so like victims of 9 11 there's 3
000 like you can immediately figure that
out right like Holocaust like records of
that exist you know what I mean you
can't lie that your family fled
persecution when they were in Brazil
during the [__] Holocaust you know
what I mean they had a hard time in
Brazil and uh yeah sure which is another
it's like a Larry David joke yeah my
family suffered a lot during the
Holocaust yeah in Brazil yeah they were
still suffering I didn't I didn't say
where they suffered the whole world
suffered yeah yeah exactly we were all
suffering it was a difficult time
yeah um he uh helped run an alleged
hedge fund Ponzi scheme which of course
you gotta do that he started working a
Florida investment firm immediately
Florida investment firm you know that
[__] is not run right okay you know this
upon this game yeah called Harbor City
capital
when he was employed there in 2020
Santos said he managed a 1.5 billion
dollar fund and bragged record returns
to 12 to 26 depending on the type of
investment boom hold on he said he had
12 to 26 returns yeah Ponzi that's
literally if you're getting that kind of
returns your your um you're getting mad
off yeah you're getting mad
dude it's a Florida investment firm
sorry like you know what you were
getting into retirees Bank America
Florida bro stop
um the company's promise they had a full
Bank guarantee on investments was bogus
Deutsche Bank claims it is a complete
fraud and not signed by the bank officer
on the document in April 2021 the
Securities and Exchange Commission
accuse Harvard city of being a Ponzi
scheme that sold 17 million dollars from
investors the company's assets are
currently in mediation with an
independent receiver appointed to manage
them it's all going on while he gets
elected to congress yeah like Financial
disclosure so this is the spicy part
this is what I I personally believe will
probably get him clapped because like
Republicans are disgusting freaks
they're sick perverts they will never
impeach uh one of their own when they're
a valuable vote and right now there's a
slim majority in the car in in the House
of Representatives as we saw with the
never cover Saga right
um so
for that reason they're never going to
like actually impeach him but he could
technically go to jail or there could
come a point where he is it is
impossible for him to continue being a
representative and I believe that that's
campaign Finance violations yes so it's
worth mentioning that meanwhile as all
this is coming out this guy ran his
whole campaign he was elected by the
People based on a total far so this
guy's no experience he has no
credentials
um and meanwhile Kevin McCartney
McCartney McCarthy is very own
supporting him
and assigning him to a committee
position midi position yeah and and part
of the reason why is because he was like
a loyal vote for Kevin uh in the in the
never cover Saga so now there's a
financial disclosure from 2022
Congressional Campaign show that he
claimed he made between 3.5 million and
11 million for the company before it was
dissolved last year which is a lie then
also records show that Santos donated
over 700 000 to his own campaign in 2022
now if it's your actual money that you
have in your pocket
you know American laws you can't stop
that it would be allowed however
his income when he ran previously in
2020 was 55 000 a year now in 2022
filings his net worth is spiked to 11
million but after his involvement with
the alleged Ponzi scheme and he's
clearing that he paid his own he's
claiming that he paid his own campaign
to the tune of seven hundred thousand
dollars from the company that he was
running a Ponzi scheme with Harbor
Capital excuse me yeah yeah
[Music]
criminal yeah reporting from talking
points memo showed that Santos campaign
staffers charged a credit card on file
for donors without their permission and
all the huge unexplained expenses and
payments to Anonymous as well as
payments of themselves he also has
another he has a history of like
misusing you know GoFundMe and donation
funds he added like a 501c3 that he set
up for rescuing animals okay saving
animals and paying for animal surgery a
uh a veteran had like a service dog I
have that video we're gonna watch that
yeah a veteran at a service dog he
literally uh took here raised three
thousand dollars for him let's watch the
video this one I watched this for the
first time when Shredder was in the
hospital and I was like this guy needs
to go down this is the worst thing I've
ever seen stealing money from himself
even stealing I know I'm about to get
banned right now we have no idea by the
way don't don't do it don't get no
straggles you're way too comfortable
with this no strike business
don't do it don't do it don't do it
[Music]
Mike's muted
all right I'm gonna release you I'm good
be good but I was gonna say like this
guy stole like millions of dollars from
people listen I don't care about that
what he did to this dog is Unforgivable
[Music]
y'all are not ready for this George
Santos claiming the congressman promised
to help his service dog get life-saving
surgery in 2016. but after about three
thousand dollars of donations poured in
the Navy veteran says Santos stopped
replying to his calls to his texts
the veteran never saw a die his dog
passed away months later and the
fundraiser was set up under a charity
group that Santos actually mentioned on
his campaign website you see it here in
a paragraph that has since been deleted
it claimed that he rescued 2400 dogs at
280 cow cats Santos also touted the
charity in this interview
I mean we we had a great organization we
were able to save animals dogs cats
horses I mean at one point this guy is
legitimately psycho wait I I can't watch
this whole 10 minute video but
uh here uh I guess we're almost to the
the meat of it yeah eight baby jumping
goats in my car
there's no record of this group in the
IRS database nor is there one among the
registered charities in New York or
Florida and the website GoFundMe where
this fundraiser was posted said that the
organizer the name is so fake it reminds
me of George costanzas uh The Human Fund
right he's like uh saving dogs is George
Costanza yeah he totally is he totally
is Larry David right this is oh my God
down to the [__] I feel like the
sweater vest look is like uh like that's
some [__] Larry David would wear he does
wear the little content oh of course he
he wears the long sleeve tees and he'll
put us he'll put a suit over it you know
what I mean drag it over the long sleeve
tees of look too this is exactly what
George wore when he worked for the
Yankees stop laughing it's not funny as
her failed to respond to all their
inquiries about where the funds went
never gave any proof of anything and so
they banned Santos's account from the
site
this comes in the context of Santos
apparent lies on everything from this
charity to where he went to college
where he worked even his claims that his
grandparents fled the Holocaust
and it goes on and on the house
Republican leadership continues to stand
by Santos tonight putting him on two
committees just this week
by the way Democrats are so stupid for
like not using this like I If you're a
Democrat worth their assault why aren't
you weaponizing this daily like I would
only talk about George Santos yeah like
do you Republicans want to [__] act
like you're pure meanwhile you've got
this [__] going on like get the [__] out
of here uh today do you think
Republicans would ever allow something
like this
Tucker Carlson would only talk about
also they would get the dams to
I mean they the perfect example of this
is Al Franken at the time when Roy Moore
was be incredibly accused of being a
pedophile in [__] Alabama the police
made him stop going to the mall because
he was constantly you know uh trying to
pick up pick up young girls at the mall
in his like local mall
Republicans turned around and and uh had
Fox News uh radio host uh that that used
to do tours with Al Franken come out and
be like Oh Al Franken you know took this
like weird photo with me many many years
ago and then Democrats in unison
collectively were like all right you're
done you're out and Al Franken resigned
yeah you know what I mean I know and
like yeah sure Al Franken weird uh did
some weird [__] okay I'm I'm not exactly
fond of the person uh in particular or
his politics but ultimately I'm using
this as an example to show you like how
what what it takes for Democrats to like
immediately uh fire off uh for someone
from their ranks and how quickly they
get duped into this cycle uh versus the
Republicans will always stand by they
stood by Roy Moore they literally Al
Franken [__] Roy Moore was literally
banned from a mall you guys
in Alabama dude it was Alabama it's like
incest and pedophilia is like a part of
the culture you know what I mean that's
crazy oh here's a recut actually of the
of uh yeah I don't remember this
interesting
well it does yeah totally
yeah
another veteran who's making the claims
against Santos and Michael Bell the
founder of the New Jersey Veterans
Network who tried to intervene and get
the money from Santos so look I'm I'm so
glad to speak to both of you and Rich
you know you served in the in the U.S
Navy I know your service dog
he's from New Jersey
your sound bite you're way too advanced
here on another plane this is why the
American Military is losing Wars bro
these two [__] thumb looking dudes
couldn't get money couldn't get three
thousand dollars out of George Santos
the [__]
they should especially the New Jersey
veteran guy like what are you doing
I think they didn't know where he was I
think
I think he talks about it in this but
I'm pretty sure they couldn't find him
like he he straight up was like we
couldn't find Osama oh I see yeah
exactly something to say about that
Santos is in a suburb of in Pakistan
right now yeah next to the [__]
Pakistan Annapolis
here you you wanted to bring her I had
to bring her yeah
that's all I have left of her and you
know that's [__] when George Santos
who at the time I guess you knew him as
Anthony devolder when he was going to
help you to save her she was suffering
from cancer at the time what did he
promise that he was going to do for
Sapphire he was going to use his uh
charity uh his 501k friends of pets
United to um
raise raise funds over GoFundMe yes dog
said he was very um so sad very
respected he was very um
he he had he had his
feelers out and with his charity it
would help me very much to get to get
the uh uh money in a sooner amount of
time than later
um you were homeless at the time I was
homeless at the time I had broken an
ankle really bad couldn't work for a
year and a half so I couldn't pay my
rent and I was evicted I was living in a
tent on the side of Route the American
dream right there my friends yeah you go
to war you get [__] up you come back
you're you know you're additionally
traumatized by being [__] homeless
you know it's great good stuff American
Dream Baby
House of Representatives
um and she had already had that growth
growing it was getting bigger and bigger
by the minute it seemed
um I finally decided to take her to the
vet to see what they could do to have it
take have it removed and they gave me a
three thousand dollar quote
um I was homeless I didn't have any
means to pay for that at all so one of
the vet techs in the place uh said hey I
know this guy
um he runs a charity uh and he saves a
lot of animals um
and she was like you want me to hook you
up with him so she took pictures of me
and Sapphire she sent them to Anthony
devolder and uh
the GoFundMe started uh it was up and
running I put it on my Facebook page uh
my friends and family donated to it they
shared it
um
I had a lot of my Navy buddies I don't
understand like what kind of [__]
Charities were used to take his fans and
family raised the money
how's that charity
yeah he set up the GoFundMe because it's
all him he set up to go for me you don't
understand he did everything a GoFundMe
setting up a GoFundMe is very difficult
okay is that how we got it very
difficult and then there's the cost of
running the business it actually
much to everyone's surprise it is
exactly the amount of value that they
raised the amount of dollars that George
Santos raised he had to dump back into
the operational cost right ironic
because like that's kind of how a lot of
501c3s operate for the record uh for
those of you in the chat that don't
understand like a lot of a lot of these
501c theories are [__] major scams so
George isn't technically doing anything
all that different but uh you know it's
still [__] up because there are real
victims of of uh charity fraud like this
it's so this guy's one of them I mean
his friends and family raised all the
money it's insane there's actually I
mean hundreds towards it
uh there were some other donors that I
didn't ever know recognize their names
or anything they might have been through
his organization they might have been
friends with friends for all I know
um so we raised three thousand dollars
in two months maybe three months
um it was six years ago uh
and as soon as the money came through I
was like great save your dog if we can
get it right in get this done
um Mr divulder did not but Santos uh
decided that he did not want me to use
my local vet
uh he wanted me to use his vets in Long
Island or Queens I don't remember which
borough or town it was in
um and that was the only way he was
going to let it happen so we took him to
we took the dog to the vet
um and the vet said well we believe this
is too vascular it's inoperable
um but we'd like to go and have her uh
have a have an ultrasound to so we can
see if we can do anything with it
um I don't drive
I paid a friend to bring it up there
real name oh his name isn't fake no
Anthony devolder is the name that like
everyone knew him as before that was
just fake yeah yeah and he says his name
is like uh you know George Anthony
devalder Santos yes the volder was his
mother's maiden name so yeah use that
sometimes that was his con name I guess
nice what's that I paid the tolls the
gas lunches and
uh devolder was supposed to pay me back
for that I even was dumb enough to give
him my my bank account and my routing
number because he said he was going to
put the money right into my account
never happened that was when I started
smelling something fishy and and and so
at one point at this point Michael you
you get involved to try to help him get
the money and so what you had
conversations with Santos again at this
time you knew him as Anthony
okay what were those like yeah my goal
was just to speak to a charity to
another charity the last thing in my
crossed my mind was that it was going to
be a problem it's the first right so you
weren't like this is
going to solve this and get him his
money rich and said to him say listen
this shouldn't be a problem it's
probably a misunderstanding at best
relax nobody's visiting him and we'll
work it out when I called him my
intentions were just to settle this
really quickly and move on but the
problem was is that when I spoke to him
on the phone he was not listening to
what I was saying he already made up his
mind I said to him can you please give
the money back to the the people or
there's a veterinarian in Rich's area
that we can give the money to and put it
into like a fund where he could use it
from time to time it's not your money to
keep and he just wasn't hearing it I
called Rich back horrified I was really
upset because this is Rich's Lifeline I
work with veterans every day and dogs
save people's lives you know and he
needed this dog every day to be in his
life and I felt horrible to tell him
that I failed him because of feeling
that Mr holder at the time was going to
do the right thing and he did not and
and you never got a dollar of the money
never got anything
of like saving his dog that's like the
greatest he's he's just such a yeah uh
he impersonated Kevin McCarthy's Chief
of Staff to raise campaign funds from
wealthy donors uh wealthy donors receive
calls and emails from a man who said he
was Dan Meyer McCarthy Chief of Staff
during the 2020 and 2022 election Cycles
according to people familiar with the
matter his name was actually Sam melee
and he worked for Santos raising money
for his campaign so like even people he
had in his ranks either under the
direction of George Santos or on their
own volition were also doing cons which
I respect uh he lied about being a real
estate manager one of the one uh one
through line through all of his scams
and cons is that like whenever George
Santos says something it's usually the
exact opposite he claimed that he had a
real estate portfolio with 13 properties
when in fact he had actually been uh
evicted uh four times
he lied about being married to a man and
lied by a mission about being married to
a woman his campaign bio discussed his
husband with whom he lives in Long
Island along with four dogs but Santos
never appeared on the campaign trail
with his partner The Daily Beast could
not find a uh marriage record in New
York and
um in 2019 however Santos did actually
uh divorce a woman uh divorce a person
that person was a woman in Queens he
said I'm very much gay which I do
believe I I do believe he's gay
um he lied about having employees who
died in the polls nightclub shooting
which was [__] insane that's crazy he
said he lost four employees in the Pulse
Nightclub shooting in 2016.
um that was not real uh he lied about
his grandparents being Holocaust victims
uh we already talked about that and um
speaking of gay
now this wasn't usually an issue this
was not an issue like drag queens were
not a a prominent culture War talking
point until like the last I would say
four or five years you had drag queens
who were like pro-trump if you remember
there was a pro-trump drag queen in the
2016 campaign uh like cross-dressing and
drag is a prominent fixture in theater
and in in movies and in art uh
throughout history right and certainly
American movie as well Eddie Murphy's
entire career Tyler Perry uh you have uh
Mrs Doubtfire things like that that we
all grew up with and yet now Republicans
have decided to make this a cultural War
issue and turns out we found out that uh
George Santos who actually received
donations uh and and uh got like a major
backer by a prominent New York
Republican who is anti-drag who is
anti-trans and and you know very much
like leading the effort in the anti-drag
stuff
um George Santos himself was a drag
queen this man says drag queens are
groomers you guys have heard that check
this out check this [__] out
look at how [__] happy he is right
now
that is our Queen that's our Queen
that's that's uh
and he he is I mean she's slaying she's
absolutely slaying she's living her best
[__] life that's right Eula Rochelle
she is so happy
Queen Brazilian drag queen who was
friends with George Santos when he lived
near Rio said she and everyone else knew
him as Anthony never George or by his
drag name Katara ravash I believe yes
Katara confirms that there was a photo
she released a photo uh from him and
dragon 2008 at a drag show in ikarai
Beach
oh this is awesome man
in the red
he vehemently denies that that's him
that's not true he used to he used to
deny it you are missing key parts of the
information so George Santos the media
comes out says that's not real that's
not true whatever and then like more and
more information come out because he's
been on camera and he ultimately gets
caught I think he was like walking uh in
an airport or something and and people
are asking him about uh the the drag
stuff and he it says yes I was young and
having fun I am by no means a drag queen
uh so I guess there's a uh there's Queen
and he owned it but that's still crazy
because he says he's young and having
fun I think that's what that's what I
thought they were doing too but it turns
out I mean from his own words here
uh which I can't hear
is that something back there
uh don't say there you go
this is here Congressional candidate in
New York's third congressional district
oh yeah this isn't related so this is
this is him supporting the don't say gay
bill I was just giving this an example
that he's yeah and he claims to the left
on creating a false narrative because
they want to groom our kids that's what
he said he said like and and obviously
that ties along with like being you know
queer
um even though you know queer
Republicans are like the LGB Coalition
or whatever the [__] routinely forget
that like Republicans despise gay people
too and think they're also freaks that
want to groom the children
um here I want to watch this video of
him talk about the Florida Bill don't
say gay
although the bill doesn't mention those
words that's what the left-leaning
Democrats and progressives are labeling
it I'll leave you with this as a gay man
I stand proudly behind not teaching our
children sex or sexual orientation
that's incumbent on the parents not
Educators the scientists you have my
full-blown support and I support your
decision to protect our children's
innocence I stand proudly behind the
Florida legislature for putting a decent
bill that will protect values thank you
finally a sane gay person we can all
support
yeah
um he's great there's no way he's gay
he's lied about everything dude he is so
gay yeah first of all I mean this is
like deep cut uh gay Twitter [__] but
like
he's mischievous and devious in a very
gay way okay
we can bring that in like the homophobic
straight guy saying like gays are
devious I mean like
like he he did drag like he he he's
super gay
the only the only non-gay fact about him
is that sweater vest okay that's the
only thing that like just you know sets
off my gaydar in the opposite direction
my favorite is when people keep asking
Kevin McCarthy about it he keeps going
listen he was duly elected I was like
[__] duly elected what the [__] are
you talking about you literally
lies about everything yeah they they
elected a fictional character like you
like look Kevin McCarthy not gay okay
like you think this guy and like look at
the the sassiness the Charisma of Kevin
McCarthy who just looks like a wet
noodle and then George Santos who was
able to con thousands of people okay you
think that's a gay a gay swag yes he has
gay 100 yeah all right
drag race because he had uh back and
forth with uh Trixie Mattel on Twitter
and in that back and forth he literally
admits that he watches the show because
uh here hold that up it's on the it's on
the dock I mean yeah it's number five
here
um he says I have now been enshrined in
late night TV history with all these
impersonations but they are all terrible
so far John love is supposed to be one
of the greatest comedians of all time
and that was embarrassing for him not me
these comedians need to step their game
up Trixie Mattel responds maybe the
source material was weak 29 000 likes by
the way George Santos responds with a uh
GIF of Trixie saying clearly you know
all about at weak acting skills it's a
gif
um with a gif yeah and then Trixie
responds I am not an actor I was young
and I had fun at a festival that is in
reference to what uh said about doing
drag George Santos replies it's all good
I won my race against the fan favorite
too
drag race but like clearly that's
something that I assume happened in this
uh in in that season Olivia can you
confirm I know you're a massive fan that
is that deep yes George Santos knew that
Trixie really [__] up snatch game when
she did her impression because she
normally slays it on her other show wow
so she got really clowned on for that
there you go here's here's Kevin
McCarthy who uh who just loves uh
he loves Georgie Boy claims to not like
drag is getting dragged all around the
timeline
I don't see any way that he's going to
have top secret if you're referring to
George Santos he's got a long way to go
to earn trust but the one thing I do
know for us
he's going to talk about trust yeah how
about how about you you I mean look that
dead dog he trusts Marjorie Taylor green
as well and we all know why he's trusted
Marjorie Taylor green okay I'm saying it
I'm [__] saying it Kevin McCarthy I
believe is having sexual intercourse
with Marjorie Taylor Greene it's like
[__] horndog I believe it you heard
it here her T levels are through the
roof because she's doing you know
Kipping
wait what
Kipping CrossFit what the [__] was that
[Music]
the voters of his district have elected
him he is seated he is part of the
Republican I mean friends you basically
if you you might as well just like if I
get elected I might as well just send
someone else and be like well he was
elected I mean literally they did not
vote for him they voted for some
fictional character that he made in a
laboratory I mean the seat that Kevin
McCarthy is currently occupying at this
moment used to be held by the
longest-running pedophile uh who also
happened to be the longest running uh
speaker of the house so really it's the
same seat well no no not the same seat
Dennis hat sorry it's not his uh it's
not the same thing but the same position
that he has right okay as a speed is the
speaker of the house was uh occupied as
a record holder by uh Dennis hastert for
uh most pedophilia allegedly well not
allegedly he went to prison for that but
I don't know if he's a record holder for
most pedophilia but um
also uh record holder for longest
running speaker of the house so we know
Republicans don't give a [__]
no matter there are concerns about it so
he will go before ethics if anything is
found to be have wrong he will be held
accountable exactly as anybody else in
this body would be
that is the fair way to handle anything
you go and that's how I'll deal with any
single issue ethics committees
I mean he says that I don't know they're
like these guys I mean in the you'd
think if like there were questions they
would hold off on like giving him
important like assignments but like we
said he's already been given positions
on the small business committee the guy
who's currently being investigated for
running a Ponzi scheme is on the small
business committee yeah I see he's on
the committee for business transparency
and Truth
excuse me Ponzi schemes are at the heart
of America's small business
sorry I see here he's on the uh
committee for
um uh truth the truth and Justice
committee yeah put him on put him on the
Ethics Committee yeah but I'm on the
Animal Welfare business ethics yeah yeah
it's great all right there it is I know
you gotta go
we did it we've been here we've done it
George I think he could be president
[__] it
it's a shame about the dog thing because
otherwise it's all really funny to me
yeah that's the one that it's like oh
wow the thing is if you put a face to
all the people he probably stole money
from but it's easy because they don't we
don't know who they are
there's always some woman who's like I
spent my whole life savings giving
George yeah now I can't afford my
insulin the other element here first of
all uh he could absolutely become
governor in Florida I mean literally
[__] uh uh what's his face Rick uh
God the one that looks like Voldemort I
always forget his name Rick Scott uh was
uh you know charged with the largest
Medicare fraud in American history and
then Florida was like that's going to be
our governor wait he was doing Medicare
fraud like yeah team him he yeah his
company the that he ran was still I
think uh was it 12 million hold on
people have done bigger ones than that
no no no no one of the large this is one
of the largest yeah
historic 1.7 billion Medicare oh I was
wrong here yeah way more billion and
that's 1.7 billion that's what the [__]
I'm talking about my man
he's all he's like yo
we need
why the lower taxes
like when I go to his Wikipedia it
doesn't show his like you know it's not
like a fat like accusations criminal
right
yeah I see that he's got a good TR firm
you got Awards and honors uh
controversial Investments does that
count yeah that's a very sanitized way
oh and by the way he stole a 2.3 billion
dollars from the federal government
anyway back to uh how great of a guy he
is yeah
he's like listen I'm not in favor of
social medicine so I'm just scooping it
up make sure it doesn't go to the poor
people oh true yeah now he you know now
his entire purpose in the Republican
party is to like cut uh more
entitlements cut more benefits cut
Social Security I tell you what he's
running on all the time [__] idiots
dude I got it I just I despise how
stupid Republicans are sometimes like
you think that guy has got your best
interest at heart he's just like
literally grafting you he's just skull
[__] you every day and openly showing
his disdain For the Working Poor and
you're like nah that's my guy he doesn't
have any [__] qualities if you ever
listen to him if you ever watch him he's
not like he's a particularly charismatic
person either he looks like [__]
Voldemort you know what's interesting
here he's you see he's smiling the eyes
they are not smiling right that is death
yeah you know why because the only time
he's ever smiled is when he's stealing
from the when he's robbing the poor okay
and he hasn't robbed the poor in a while
his eyes have the death stare he they're
almost like they look like he's in
Terror smile
Terror
this guy's seeing the darkness he's
gazed into the he's peered into the void
and it appeared back yeah
let's see if we can catch what's in the
reflection of his eye what the [__] is
that a body no that's Satan is that a
pitchfork flames of Hell couldn't be is
that the screams of Oblivion of all lost
souls
I just you know there's no there's
nothing because karmic Justice that
these demons keep surviving yeah like
you know the poor and needy day
I can hear the screams and blood
chilling cries of
helpless
Millions were perished and because they
did not accept Jesus they weren't
baptized so they went straight to hell
and there Rick feasts on their souls
the smile says Hassan's got to go yeah
but the eyes I know I know you're really
into this right now all right all right
thanks Hassan uh we covered a lot of
ground here today so that's good hell
yeah you know what that's awesome
and we praise Dale baby I wanted to ask
you about the Bradley Octonauts he has
not responded to me yet I said what do
you make of this blood work I send it to
him like my t-level oh [__] let me know
what he says I will I'll let you know
bring the results next week we'll keep
you posted should I send him my blood
be like dude you're dying I mean I don't
know Dr Bradley Martin tell me you
should get your you should get your
blood work done though regardless yeah
you're right all right guys see you
tomorrow oh Rebecca Black's coming
tomorrow oh hell yeah she dunked the
[__] on Andrew Tate oh yeah dude
grinding feminist uh icon
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
with the uh Rebecca Black and uh God
bless
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you